our first speaker is
we'll talk about the representation
supported by the coffee closure
thank you very much and thanks to the
organizers for the invitation
uh
I do not have really very new results
so you may have some of you may have
heard this
this are some variant of this talk but I
do see at least some new phases so maybe
it will not be a totally futile exercise
so let me
let me begin with some notation
so let's see
how do I erase Ah that's here
thank you
I have to go here okay
so
so let
me be a vector space
Dimension M and the CJ Vector space
everything is going to be our complex
numbers
so let's start with Vector space of
Dimension m
and let
the into morphism of V which is also
same as V Stars
so this of course
and
now we have a function from E to C
which is the determinant function so if
I take a m by m Matrix I can take its
detectable
and determinant of course is is a
polynomial of degree m
uh so it's a polynomial of degree M so I
can think of determinant as an element
in s m
of e star
so I just think of this eigen element in
the ml symmetric power of the Dual of E
and thought of this I am just going to
write this Edge
I mean I'm just thinking of the
community element here and thought of
this eigen element here I will just
write it with a capital debt
now g l e
X
on of course e is the uh is the standard
representation and hence an e star and
hence under symmetric power so GLA acts
on on let's call this something so let's
call this Q
so X on E and hence on Q
so I can take the GLE orbit closure
of this determinant function so this is
a Subspace of Q and sub space not like
the vector service based on variety of Q
and I can take its closure
so this is going to be one object which
I will just call it X that
so that's one object the other object is
so let's fix two things let's fix n less
than M and also
fix a basis
of V
and let's call it e i so
this is
so then I can Define this a pi date
permanent function
I'm going to call it p m n
so this depends upon this pair MN so pmn
is nothing but okay so since I have
fixed a basis of V then I can write in
the element e as a m by m Matrix
so
so let's write this okay so this is
going to be a matrix
and by n size
actually no sorry
I mean it doesn't matter but let's
follow what I have
so let's just write x 1 1 here
and in this bottom
right corner I will put this n by n
Matrix
okay so this is M by m Matrix so okay
h
so let's call it
a n
so this is going to be okay so this is
oh oops not get a minute
this is X one one to the power M minus n
times permanent of a n
divided to write this
where a is now
oops
maybe I should not try it too below okay
so this is again now for a m by m Matrix
I am taking this this entry the first
entry arranging it to power M minus n
and then multiplying that by permanent
of this bottom right n by n block
s in this diagonal that's what you mean
in this description of the Matrix a you
have X11 occurs along this main diagonal
no just there's just one no no no no no
no no
yeah
it's just a number
he is
important so it's always
he's not using all his coordinates it's
just yes I okay
so a is a m by m Matrix I just write it
as x i j okay
maybe it's not your fault maybe it's
money
my fault okay
so now again this becomes a polynomial
of degree m
okay because this is a polynomial of
degree n and now I have uh blasted it or
spotted it by a minus 10 degree so it's
a polynomial of degree m so again I can
think of this
Edge
and element so again I'm going to think
of p m n element in s m of E
and again I mean I can take the g l e
orbit
of this v m n and I can take its closure
and I'm just going to call it XP
and I mean I should really say MN
okay so now these are two close sub
varieties of Q
so they are both so X
debt
and x p m n
are both
closed
cones
in q
so they are both closed cones means that
they are they are invariant are stable
under sea star uh usual homo30 action
so in particular so this implies that if
I take the affine coordinate ring
and
this
so this is a fine coordinate ring
r
uh modules
for the group GLE which I'm just going
to call it Edge G
so these are modules
now now let's
so I am going to Define two numbers
so I think I'm just going to not
Bend myself too much
so ah there is also M and E
which is in all the N by in my Trice h
uh off
n by n type
so M and E
also acts on this debt
mind that usually the action is by G
inversed
so usually the action so G on on on any
function f on a element X is f of G
inverse X but I'm just going to change
it into a right action so M and E will
act on the right so but but that's not
going to change the orbit structure so
I'm not going to worry about that
so I'll just say that this is the right
actions I'll just continue right so
that's
uh that's also sitting in q
so now let's define two numbers Fix N
and let
m n
and M Bar n
be the smallest
integers
so that
this uh
uh right so that this
uh
so I'll just consider this orbit g l e
of this permanent
is sitting inside
this one
okay and E
so uh so that okay right so
and similarly
uh let's take M Bar n
the smallest
yeah
so that
this X
ah
well it's sitting inside
so now Valiant
and this is 1979
made a conjecture
that this function m n
m n is not dominated
by any polynomial
and
so this is
some algebraic version
of cooks
famous
P not equal to NP okay h
right okay so I mean
even though I do not understand but
since there are many computer scientists
here so maybe I will just say this
is the statement that this perm
does not belong to this class v p
that's what this means now clearly
M Bar n
is less than equal to MN
so M Bar N is less than equal to I mean
clearly because the orbit M and E of
course
GLE is dense in m and E so in particular
the GLA orbit closure will contain at
least M and E
so M Bar N is less than equal to MN and
now
ah
male
I'm sorry
in a series of papers
uh more than half a dozen
papers ah they I mean the mid conjecture
not in half pigeon papers but they made
this conjecture that even this function
M Bar n
does not
is not dominated by
autonomy
of course since M Bar n is less than
equal to MN of course if you prove this
conjecture then you would have variance
conjecture uh immediately
and again
for the computer scientists
this means that perm n n bigger than
equal to 1 does not belong to this class
v p w s bar
but
nobody will ask me what it means so
okay
right so naturally they uh they they
means and Sony made this conjecture that
M Bar N is not dominated by any
polynomial function but they also LED
out a program as to how to prove it now
the advantage
at least for for people like me who who
dabble into algebra geometry and
reproduction theory is that this object
is more readily uh
uh can be used in algebra geometry and
represent Theory and that's where I'm
coming to
okay
so maybe I should at least keep this
notation V Dimension m
uh
e is endomorphism V and Q is s m e
is
okay so now so as I said
I mean
and Sony made this conjecture but they
laid out a program and this program is
as follows
so
so the question is when does X this
sperm
m n sits inside X stat
so let's start
I let's find the the first M the
smallest M where it stops to be there so
okay so I I have to say something so for
large M if you fix an N for large n it's
a old result that indeed this variety is
sitting inside this for a large M
compared to n and this is roughly of the
order of 2 to the power n r 2 to the
power n plus one something like that
so this is this variety is contained in
here for large m
so now you want to look for the smallest
M where it's Siege to be not contained
in there
so let's say that it's contained in
there so the affine coordinate ring of
this
will subject onto the affine coordinate
ring
of this one
I mean it's a it's a sub variety if it
is contains if
okay
so if this is contained then because
it's a closer variety both are fine so
then I defined coordinate ring level
this Mark will be subjective and of
course this is embedding G embedding
so it's a g equivalent embedding so this
will be a g module map
so in particular if this is rejective so
in particular
if I take any representation of G so
keep in mind that g e g l e so if I take
any representation G sorry V Lambda
foreign
Parts because we are taking G of g l e
and e is M Square dimensional so V
Lambda so Lambda is a partition into at
most M Square parts so in particular
multiplicity right
so we'll so Multiplicity
of V Lambda in
C of x
per MN will be less than equal to
multiplicity
Lambda and this side
so in fact
and Sony
not normally conjecture that M Bar N is
is not a polynomial or not dominated by
a polynomial but they also said that ok
so so this is another conjecture
and this conjecture says that
that if no
right X bar so this
let's write it precisely so for any
M bigger than n
X
param
n sits inside X that if I'm only if
there exists
1 V Lambda or some V Lambda
such that this Multiplicity
uh
is strictly bigger than
so one side I've already shown you it's
trivial but they conjectured that it's
the other side now
depending upon the day and the sunlight
I believe or not believe in this
conjecture so so uh so uh
today it's sun it's cloudy so I don't
know I'm a little bit more gloomy today
conjunction was slightly less
um strong than you stated okay
it's just conjectures that it's not for
every m m it's just that there exists
sequences perhaps very sparse
subsequences okay is that
it's okay but today is
okay so so I stand corrected so in any
case I mean there is some some yeah yeah
right exactly Okay so
right
so at the very least
I would say that this seems rather hard
and
this is a rather hard uh uh uh
problem of course I of course uh
uh right so
so let me give you two and which
probably should be called as somewhat
negative results
so what one is looking for so one is
looking for a representation V Lambda
which occurs on the permanent side but
it does not occur on the determinant
side right so suppose I will to prove
that
that every representation occurs in the
determinant side so suppose
hypothetically suppose I wear to prove
that every representation occurs on the
determinant side
then forget it right
right then then you you can't hide this
approach of course I mean you could
refine it that the multiplicity should
be bigger because but this
conjecture that not only the
multiplicity but even the occurrence uh
uh gets a problematic right so I will
just say
that
many times there are two different
varieties
which have the same affine
coordinatoring not as a ring but as a g
module and in fact the result by Bria
and Alexa
which says that let's take a g variety a
fine G variety and let's take is a fine
coordinate ring which is FG module and
now let's look for all a fine G
varieties which have the same
a fine coordinate ring just as a g
module not a hearing structure of course
the ring structure will completely
determine the variety but just SG module
so this this family of such a fine
variety is form itself a scheme so there
is a model I and this has been studied
actually in a in some series of papers
by Bria and Alexa and also it's being
followed up by by some other Italians uh
so so this stage definitely the
representations occurring in a fine
coordinate ring does not determine the
varieties so that's definitely and
they're very simple examples in
repetition Theory where this phenomenon
occurs
exactly what I said
okay could you repeat what you said ah
okay so now you ask me the correct
question then
so let's take a g variety a fine G
variety X okay and let's look for a fine
coordinate ring it's the G module now I
fixed X now I look for all possible
affine varieties why such that they are
fine no G variety why so that the affine
coordinatory not as a ring but as a g
module is isomorphic together with the
multiplicity
such y form itself a scheme so there is
a moduli so I'm fixing that
so it's a positive dimensional it could
be Zero Dimensional sometimes and it
could be positive dimensional sometimes
that was my question right okay right so
so many times it's positive dimensional
but sometimes it could be rigid and it
could be Zero Dimensional
but there has been a a a a fair amount
of study about about this uh this model
I so the point I am making
complexity is very different from
I
I just want to say that the module
structure does not determine the the uh
the variety that's what I just that's
all I I'm saying okay so now one
one very traditional way in repetition
Theory at least you study C of any G
variety X
typically what you do
that X is normal then you take the and
suppose X is G orbit closure so suppose
X is some G orbit closure
a single G orbit closure so the way you
study the affine coordinate ring of X
typically is you study the affine
coordinate ring of GV which is generally
very simple object because it's nothing
but you take ring of functions on G and
you take H invariant where H is the
stabilizer of a
and I find coordinate ring of G of
course is given by the petrol theorem as
a g module so in principle that's a very
easy problem but the hard part is these
are functions only defined on the open
orbit how to extend them and this
extension problem
is generally difficult
but if you you have a normal variety and
you have some control on the divisors at
Infinity then then you you may have
control and there are many many
reposition theoretic situations where
that's exactly what happens that you
have a normal variety and you have some
control on this complement of this open
orbit
and you you can use that quite
powerfully to study so first negative
result
and
that both have
X that
and xperm MN
are
Mac normal
and in fact normally they are not normal
but I suspect that the non-normal locus
is really very large so it's not that it
fails in a in a moderate way actually it
fails terribly but that's not something
I proved that's my my hunch that this
will be not normal okay
the next result
when something's not normal
how I took the non-normal locus has a
minimum
code dimension
non-normality yes okay now you can ask
this subriety is Zero Dimensional
one-dimensional or one billion
dimensional correct so I'm saying that
my hunch is that it will be one billion
dimensional not Zero Dimensional
sorry in terms of the co-dimension
that's what I'm saying so so Co
Dimension could be actually my hanshi
the coda medicine is actually two
exactly exactly
yes right okay so now
I should say that only General
positive result
is due to
to Landsberg and manival and research
and that is
let's get that straight and squared plus
y
so yes so what
and all three of them are here
so they proved that this m n is at least
no sorry M Bar N is at least n square
plus one is that correct am I getting it
right
greater than or equal to N squared over
two oh N squared over two ah sorry
foreign
okay so that's the
so at least M Bar N is
quadratic in n
so that's the positive result now
okay so as I said I mean let's try to
follow this program so we are looking
for representation which occur on the
permanent side which does not occur on
the determinant side right so now first
of all let me make one simple Lemma
that any V Lambda
which occurs
in
uh in this
exponent c x bar
m n
has the property
that so this Lambda is a partition
Lambda 1 at most Lambda M Square parts
but any V Lambda which occurs in here
has the property that let's break it
here Lambda N squared plus one
so let's break there so everything so
has the property that Lambda I is 0 for
all I bigger than N squared plus 1
that's a fairly simple result I mean I
mean it does require a proof but it's
not terribly difficult
that anything which will occur on the
permanent side will have this property
now okay
also there is another simple result
which let me mention
that any V Lambda
which occurs
in either of those in c x debt r c x
sperm
MN
satisfied
the the total uh
length of no what is it called is
multiple of
it's multiple of also what is it called
I mean so so this is
number yeah so so it's summation Lambda
yeah
we start something
so that's multiple of M
okay
so now
so now I come to another theorem
and this stage
which occurs
I I did a very bad job
in
sorry
c x that
r c x sperm
MN
either of those two varieties
satisfy this property so now the next
theorem
okay
that
so take
any Lambda
such that Lambda is of the form Lambda 1
Lambda 2
Lambda M and then 0.
take any Lambda such that Lambda is up
this form
then
the M Lambda
occurs
in c x dot
now let's compare these these oops oops
sorry sorry
so let's compare all these limits and
results
so first of all any V Lambda which
occurs in this side
must
die out Beyond N squared plus one
okay so so if
N squared plus 1 is let's say
bigger no less than m
m
so let's take any squared plus 1 is less
than equal to M and we can always assume
that because there is already by result
of Landsberg manual and desire already I
mean the region a quadratic bound which
is already known
so you are trying to improve the bound
and eventually show that in fact there
is no bound right so we can always
assume that at least M Bar N is
quadratic so I am saying that let's take
any M which is bigger than equal to N
squared plus 1.
so any representation which will occur
here
will taper off Beyond M which will be 0
Beyond m so it will satisfy this
condition
s
multiplicity is a mess I tell you I mean
multiplicity is
it's a mess
so yes so so let's come back so if m is
bigger than equal to N squared plus 1 so
this sequence dies off Beyond Lambda m
even before
and this theorem says that if you go up
to Lambda M then VM Lambda occurs in
that and let's combine that any Lambda
which occurs in either of those must
satisfy that this total size of Lambda
is a multiple of M now these two do not
say
that's conjecture is false but it does
say okay but there is
ah
provided no no but
and there is a very very strong evidence
that L Antarctic conjecture is going to
be true so now I am going to talk about
L and Farsi but before I say that
what I was just saying that you know any
M Lambda
will occur here
so this is basically no constant if I am
taking M to be more than quadratic
but this is and any such Lambda which
will appear here is of the size multiple
of M and I'm saying that if you saturate
this by m then this will occur in here
provided of course this allentary
conjecture is true so it does say that
to find such a Lambda
so we need to find some Lambda which
occurs on the permanent side but does
not occur on the determinant side it
just I'm saying that this problem
becomes very difficult because now you
have to worry about see General
techniques in position Theory
are not too bad
when you go to saturation when you go to
saturation then repression theory is
more controllable
so but if you go to saturation there is
no hope that's what I'm trying to say
right okay so now
the saturated sending group because this
is exactly no if you saturate so you
can't look for exactly exactly exactly
see because with saturation there are
these hard inequalities you can deal
with lots of things you have some
control or a good control so this
theorem says forget about saturation I
mean you have to really look for needle
in a hair I mean
yeah
we discovered yesterday they're looking
for hay in a haystack it's hard too not
finding the hay in the Hastings okay
right so so these are the results now I
have not told you anything about proofs
I mean some proofs are little bit longer
than the others so they they use a
couple of things but basically a
repetition theory of gln and symmetric
group and while sure Duality and and
things like that so so not not too
sophisticated techniques it does not use
any power sheaves or anything like that
so absorb so uh so it does not yield
is it again
Okay so
the connection will be a long time yes
that's what I'm going to tell you at
least what is
the thing or that you know then then you
can just keep up now I'm sorry okay ah I
see well
it's not too hard to explain right but
it will take but
let me let me first at least
is there anyone here who does not know
what he yell and RC if everybody knows
ah then I have to explain okay
foreign
something like that
okay
uh no 1992
so this
is about these magic squares
uh what of course yeah like in scratch
isn't it also called magic squares no
that's not a manual priyans thing that's
a different thing oh is that right
somehow I okay Latin squares
of size m
so what is the Latin square of size M so
it's the M by m Matrix
then by m box
where each row
is a permutation of so each row
and each column
is a permutation
of 1 through n
1 through M
so each row is a permutation of one
through M each column is a permutation
of one through M so let's say if I take
m equals 2 then we have 1 2
and then we have 2 1 1 2
.
five
now
so to any such
uh such uh uh so this is called Latin
Square okay so I am fixing an m and
let's consider the set of all the Latin
squares now to every Latin Square you
associate a sine plus one at minus one
sine of Latin Square
so as I said every row is a permutation
of 1 through M and every column is a
permutation of 1 through m
so let's just call it permutation Sigma
1 Sigma 2 so they are these are columns
Sigma M and I'll just call S1 S2 s m
those are the the permutations of the
row which
so sine Affiliated squared is nothing
but sine
of Sigma I
from 1 to M product of sine
so you just multiply all the signs of
rows and columns that's called a sign of
a Latin Square now there is also called
a column sign
and I'm sure you can guess
what it is
and that is exactly by definition
just sine of columns so Sigma i h
I from 1 to m
so that's the this the column sign and
similarly of course you can Define the
row sine of a Latin Square now L and RC
made this following conjunction
and that is
that
okay
and this is 92
that take M even
then
number of even
Latin squares
of size m
is different from number of odd
and even just means that the sign is
plus one or is sine minus one so they
made this conjecture in 1992.
and then there was a result due to Huang
and
Rota
it said that
Ellen
oops
that's the conjecture is equivalent to
saying that the column signs
column sign
number of column
odd
that in squares
size m
is different from number of column even
okay so so so whether we take just the
column sign or the total sign it doesn't
matter so far L and tarsity conjecture
is concerned now there was two papers
Drisco and Glenn
and right
and
so there were two papers Drisco
that is 97
uh proved that Elon tarcy I'll just cite
a t conjecture is true
for m equals P plus 1 where PJ Prime
which is R Prime
and then Glenn
and that is whoops 2010 actually
I didn't realize that it was as late
it's true
for n equals P plus 1 minus oh sorry
sorry yes
exactly of course right yes otherwise it
will be scandalous that after 13 years
whatever
but each time we have one M while the
conjecture same for M same that's why
same exactly
even even no okay
I am only going to consider M even
for some reason I am only going to
consider M even and for M even yes right
good good point so take care
so actually I don't have to say that
theorem then occurs and provided
conjecture is true for
that m
for that even M so same
now okay
if I'm allowed to give an exercise
prove that for M odd
these numbers of odd is same as number
of even
assume a is prime plus one
there you go
exactly
exactly that's right
exactly that's exactly right that's
exactly the point but you see for
for a mathematician I mean
oh you can say more than one thing but
but but if you don't mind can you say it
in few minutes
okay so now this is a conjecture of
course in like combinatorics now there
are some beautiful analogues in
depression Theory which I want to to
mention
equivalent
formulation
off
Ellen Darcy actually more like this
column I will just say columnar scene
for
M even
and its
I still think it's quite appealing and
I and Joseph have spent many sleepless
nights and we have come up with many
proofs over a period of time and this is
the following so so this is the same M
so let's take s m of cm
for me so I I just
not e but let's take V and let's take
the MS symmetric power here
so I take the MS symmetric power of m s
symmetric power of v and keep in mind
that V dimension of V is m
now let's choose a basis which actually
already I chose at some point and I
called it even em
and now in smv of course we have this
element
I mean
most canonical element I mean
are okay one can debate that
but at least there is a very canonical
element E1 times E2 times e m
right so that's an element here and I
just raise it to power m
that's what I do I just made that
element to the power M so that becomes a
element here and let us just call it V
0.
so I've given you a very specific
element in this SM of SM of V and glv of
course acts on this so let's take the
glv module generated by this
so this is the glv module
generated by
okay so glb module generated by this
specific vector now so there is a simple
result
no no no
if it were highest weight Vector I don't
think that we will spend sleepless
nights on this
as we are two
ways to be a possibility I mean I don't
rule that out
I definitely do that rule that
possibility for me not for Joseph I can
definitely do not rule that possibility
for me okay
soap now it's a a a a well-known
not too hard a result
that SM of SM of V contains
a unique copy
of
SLV trivial module
that's a simple result that SM of SMF V
contains a unique copy of SLV trivial
module so now equivalent formulation so
equivalent formulation
of
column
L and r c h
that this module glv V naught
contains
this unique copy
of
trivial
SLP module
okay
it's so appealing
and I'm
as a represent theorist I mean
you feel like oh my God you should be
able to prove it in two hours right it
should not take more than two hours uh
but here it is I have already said that
I and Joseph have spent many sleepless
nights on that but that does not mean I
mean we don't have the right idea so I
really
encourage you and all
yes
without any qualification
that SM of smv contains the unique copy
of SLV trivial module
is equivalent to
saying that the glv module generated by
this specific Vector which I wrote down
yeah
contains this unique copy of SLV module
SLV trivial SLV module
so this is a g module you decompose and
it does contain the triple module in it
that's what that's what this uh and it's
an equivalent formulation okay uh
actually my time is more than up there
is one other equivalent formulation
which I and Joseph have arrived at and
hopefully it will cease light updates
sometime and it's it will take one
minute to describe that another
equivalent formulation I should really
stop but another equivalent formulation
is that you take this function
over s u m
okay you take this sum this compact
group sum
and you take the Matrix entries gij and
you take the product
the product of the Matrix entries of
this Matrix and
you take the hard measure on s u n and
this is non-zero
so this is an equivalent formulation
this was arrived at with a width uh
and so so there are and there are some
other equivalent formulations but I I I
better stop in fact I'm already
well over my time
like I mentioned just one there is a
beautiful conjecture of water so just
yes
open suspicions which is really
fantastic so
there is an equivalent formulation by
rotor
what's the difference
okay and I give you so it's end
Dimension and I give you n basis correct
this conjecture says you can rearrange
these vectors pick one vector from each
base
another one and if I remember correctly
this is first of all it's very closely
it is equality and just to if
no but before you say one more thing let
me correct you that this is not just
Rota it's Huang and Rota this is the
difference this is the colorful
conjecture not the column lens it's a
different conjecture
from and so there is work by schmorton
there's stuff that I keep saying that if
you want I can dig up for you oh I
definitely would love to
work yeah
there's more recent stuff from there so
that would be extremely interesting also
there's a more recent work by
I mean I forget the guy's name but is
there a proof more General than P minus
one and P plus one
is there a proof of Ellen tarcy Beyond P
minus one and people
there
no then you perhaps there are more cases
where the conjecture is known to be true
that's one nice thing but I'm talking
now about something here which puts me
alone in other contexts so for example
if I remember correctly it's certainly
very closely related to these water
basis right if I remember about it
perhaps even the two are equivalent
they're equally no
no no oh okay in this own article that
they're that someone probably had this
one yeah later than I did so what does
one improve I don't remember but it
he definitely does not say that they're
equivalent so how long does it implies
there is an implication but there is no
reason to work on this uh dig it up
there's a guy I previously spoken of
seminar a year ago and he's a
combinatorial theorist computer
scientist
s
oh I would I would
really be interesting to understand
which you know for me they're related
but I can't say okay
so and that is you describe it's just an
end by an array the numbers was one to
end once in everywhere and everything
equivalent it's an Empire by n a
three-dimensional array n by n by n
Zero's in one so it's a cube now
exactly yeah every nine contains exactly
one one interest on zero why you take
this thing off of The Matrix as you
describe so so it's a cube and by and by
n Cube
you can
describe as an end by enter a of zeros
and ones to every line go economy
contains exactly one one right
now take this one dimension up
it's an array of n by n by n
where the entries are zeros and ones you
want to point
in which that helps in every line so now
there are rows columns and shafts in
each one of them contains exactly one
line what's the connection is very
simple take off of the usual description
that you gave is a typographical map
which tells you in what height above
your head the wire is sitting and so I
mean there these are all objects that uh
you know I am
and I just wonder if there is more than
you know the superficial connection I
think actually one of those improves
exactly hyper geometry so this is hyper
geometric function uh uh but yeah so
this is what if I understand it
correctly it's the hypergeometric
function and Glenn
has used it very powerfully yeah
foreign
of course
exactly exactly that I mean basically
that's what kitten said no I complete
but you know mathematician you want to I
mean
you know you're not I mean actually
kitten you had some remarks son that in
complexity feeling this is a barrier
visit okay which is an Evidence against
a big like in complexity Theory there
are results like natural fruit barriers
we say that asymptotic techniques that
they were using in complexity they are
not going to work in the context of
previously
this is a similar thing which is saying
that asymptotic results are not going to
work that's precisely what I said right
so it's an analog of natural proof
barrier in complexity I see I see so it
is
like me this was expected that I say
okay okay okay I see I see
okay good that's good to know that there
is there is still some light in the day
yes
because I don't understand why why to
exclude the the multipurpose of M
implies that there is no asymptotic
absolution
there are very large Lambda which are
not multiple of ever yes but then
this sentence was uh was used several
times in this this week and I never
understand it so maybe I don't fully
understand
for multiples of tree okay they are very
big integers
so the conclusion is there is no
asymptotic
absorption and I can't understand this
this no I don't think anyone was
asserting there's no as in product
instruction
s
that there is no asymptotic you can't go
agent vertically that's what I said
so
it's something that you take the cone of
all of these and and and you can't and
you can't detect anything exactly that's
exact that's all I'm saying that's all
I'm saying
to detect what the holes are exactly
that's the point that's exactly the
point I'm making but Nicolas if you are
making something different which I am
not I'm missing so sometimes
oddness can can implying
for example
so you're thinking it may there may be
an index
like somebody being hot versus and we
know that congrators
no no that is true that is true I do
agree there
exactly absolutely no guy completely
agree but keep in mind also I mean this
Lemma too which is not on the board
anymore that the the size of Lambda has
to be multiple of M
so you have to be careful
so see there are two constraints that
any representation which occurs on the
determinant side are on the permanent
side the size of Lambda has to be
multiple of M same
so
I am not saying by no means I am saying
it's impossible I'm just saying that it
makes it a bit hard to locate such a
presentations okay
definitely not
yes are there examples where these
rights or orbit closures so two orbit
closures yes yes and also examples of
points that are that are actually
defined by their stabilizer
so whether stabilizer is yeah right I
don't know that but but for your first
question I can give you very easy
examples
right and what you do uh you take any
semi-simple D group take it slowly
algebra G
and you take a let's say a regular
semi-simple element
so let's take a regular semi-simple
element let's just call it s
now you take the adjoint orbit of this
this is already closed because it's
semi-simple okay now let's take a
regular nil potent element
so n
G and let's take this orbit and close it
up
now these are completely different
animals but they are fine coordinatoring
exactly the same representations not
normally the same representation is
occurring with the same Multiplicity
so so so you see it's not only the same
representations of the same list but
they have exact same multiplicity and
you know this is I mean this is very
simple example and you can cook up lots
of such examples
you take whatever whichever is your
favorite semi simple algebra
yes
exactly exactly exactly so I took a
regular semi-simple I could take any
semi-simple there will be corresponding
nil potential element such that the G
orbit of s will have exactly the same a
fine coordinatoring in terms of
representations
yes very very interesting examples like
this where actually the points are
defined by the stabilizers
absolutely
your remark is absolutely well taken and
it was well taken long back but
so let's continue
thank you